well residents are making their voices
heard tonight as new mask
mandates inside workplaces are set to
kick in here with about six hours away
as victoria saha reports opinions are
varied from those who don't mind to
those who say
they shouldn't have to make up for those
who refuse to get vaccinated
it's time to dig out those masks again
and although some
have not stopped wearing them every
employee will now be required to wear
one
in a workplace vaccinated or not and
some of you
are not happy about it i'm done doing
more than my part derek emig is fully
vaccinated he says this new rule is
unfair for those who got vaccinated
and now have to make up for those who
refuse to get the vaccine i'm tired of
taking care of everybody
else people need to take care of
themselves he isn't alone one woman
didn't want to be identified and says
it's confusing why do you have a mask
a band-aid when we're already vaccinated
at a shopping complex in the southwest
valley some who were vaccinated
had their masks on not wanting to take
any chances
i'm all for it i don't really want this
to continue on forever so i think the
best thing we can do
is put on our masks and do what we're
told to do and hopefully it'll go away
soon
i'm going to keep wearing it until i
know it's safe others doing what they
need to
vaccinated or not you know it should be
you know our freedom and our right to
to do one with one thing or the other
now with this new mask mandate
businesses are required to encourage
masks but some may even enforce it
before you walk in
reporting from the strip victoria saha 8
news now
by the way this latest mask ruling is
only supposed to be temporary it starts
at midnight tonight
and then it will be reviewed again on
august 17th